bon ben ça y est on y est les menthe à
l'eau on a passé les 100 mille abonnés
en moins de neuf mois c'est comme si on
avait accouché ensemble tu pas sûr que
ce soit la meilleure image non plus je
vais pas vous faire une vidéo de
remerciements larmoyante
mais avant de vous parler des nouveautés
et des petits trucs exclusive de la
chaîne je voudrais remercier de youtube
space paris qui m'a ouvert ses portes
pour les formations toutes les personnes
qui sont passées dans mes vidéos depuis
le début de cette année et qui m'ont
aussi invité dans les leurs et vous vous
enfin quand je dis vous c'est toi là qui
regarde la vidéo c'est vous tous début
janvier sur la chaîne
on était une petite centaine et si
j'avais une vidéo qui faisait les 300
vue c'est qu'elle avait pesé mais
vraiment en plus c'est à dire que 300
bus amende est hyper heureux je me dis
assez cool quand même 300 personnes qui
ont regardé les vidéos c'est formidable
et il y avait une deux personnes qui
arrivent chaque jour
et là c'était je me disais cette vidéo
était assez cool pour qu'une personne
prenne le temps de s'abonner et ça me
fait toujours peu importe les chiffres
les stats c'est toujours une belle
récompense en fait d'avoir un abonné
plus d'avoir quelqu'un qui regarde une
vidéo voilà ça c'est dingue et en fait
c'est parce que vous êtes derrière
l'écran tu es derrière ta caméra en
train de regarder la vidéo
c'est pour ça que je suis hyper motivé à
chaque fois c'est parce que vous avez
partagé que vous avez like et que vous
avez commenté que les vidéos elles se
sont fait aussi un petit peu connaître
donc je sais que je le vous le dois j'ai
pas fouillé mais j'ai pas la refaire
parce que c'est ce que je voulais dire
merci encore cent mille fois maintenant
j'ai cinq choses à vous dire j'ai cinq
réponses à des questions que vous me
posez souvent et que je prends bien le
soin d'éviter et aujourd'hui je veux
donner ces cinq réponses là dont la
réponse au fameux engagement que j'avais
pris pour les semble tout d'abord va y
avoir un petit peu de changements sur la
chaîne il va y avoir un nouveau logo une
petite intro très courte de la musique
est faite par un créateur j'avais parlé
vite fait rapidement tout sa nouvelle
fin la vidéo je voulais lancer ça pour
les cent mille mais vous êtes arrivé
beaucoup trop vite donc c'est pas encore
en place je pense que d'ici la fin du
mois vous allez voir tout ça arrivait
sur la chaîne j'espère que ça va vous
plaire deuxième chose le mental meet up
quand on était dix mille abonnés j'avais
pris un engagement que cinquante mille
abonnés je ferai un mythe c'est arrivé
tellement vite qu'à un moment donné la
barre des 50 millions ne l'a pas vu
passer donc je n'étais pas du tout prêt
à le mettre en place
alors je vous rassure je suis déjà en
train de travailler dessus il sera
sûrement fin octobre ou début novembre
et pour cette première ce sera pareil je
vous tiens au courant de tout ça mais en
attendant d'ici là si vous venez me voir
en spectacle quelque part n'hésitez pas
à m'attendre à la fin du spectacle c'est
cool quand on se rencontre après vous
avez toutes les dates sur le site www.ma
bien les gars à point fr il ya le lien
dans le descriptif tout le temps à
chaque fois la troisième chose c'est que
j'ai toujours fonctionné comme ça par
des filles
ça me stimule les deadline des trucs
comme ça quand on était à deux mille
abonnés j'avais lancé un truc pour les
10000 abonnés à 10000 abonnés j'ai pris
l'engagement pour les cinquante mille
abonnés aujourd'hui on est à cent mille
donc nouveau défi mais je garde la règle
de 5
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi vraiment depuis
une semaine je pense qu'à ça et je crois
que j'ai trouvé pas ce que voulait faire
quelque chose dans tout le monde puisse
bénéficier toute la communauté en fait
peu importe où vous êtes dans le monde
je vais organiser une soirée spéciale
dans un théâtre avec plein de choses
différentes pour une soirée que je crois
qu'il va être ou ce n'est cette soirée
elle sera rediffusée en live directement
sur youtube gratuitement pour que tout
le monde puisse en profiter en même
temps en direct alors je vous dis
sincèrement je ne sais pas encore
comment je vais le faire je ne sais pas
quel contenu va y avoir je sais pas avec
quels moyens je vais faire ça comment
l'organiser mais c'est pas grave même si
j'ai quand même unité sur le contenu ça
sera drôle ça sera mentalise ans et ce
sera interactif en tout cas d'ici qu'on
soit 500 milles sur cette chaîne dans la
communauté il peut se passer des années
donc je m'entoure est le moment venu et
on trouvera des solutions à ce moment là
je crois en sa voilà vous connaissez le
prochain défi il est à 500000 quatrième
chose qu'est ce qui se passe là
prochaine fabien est ce que tu arrêtes
les vidéos pour 2017 non j'arrête pas
évidemment après m'être lancé sur
youtube le 1er janvier si je réussi à
aller au bout du défi j'aurais fait 366
vidéo cette année une par jour sans
jamais avoir un jour mort alors je
compare relancer le même défi parce que
ça n'aurait pas de sens et là ça me
stimule vrai plus pour le coup mais bien
sûr je vais continuer déjà je vais
lancer quelques concept différent de ce
que je fais mais avec toujours le
mentalisme ans en axe principal et je
pense qu'un acquittement vous surprendre
toute manière j'ai vu reus d'éclater en
maintenant dans ces foutus et j'ai pas
défini précisément de rythme mais je
crois qu'au mois de janvier il y aura
beaucoup moins de vidéos d'habitude
parce que je vais faire une petite pause
je pense qu'après une année comme ça
j'aurais mérité une petite pause un
petit break mais ce sera pas sans vidéo
du tout ce sera juste moins deux vidéos
et ce break l'âme permettra aussi de
mettre en place les nouveautés des
nouvelles vidéos pour 2010 et enfin la
vidéo des 100000 la fameuse vidéo et des
syndicats polonais je m'en veux
tellement le 1er janvier donc ça doit
être la vidéo numéro 32 forcément le 1er
janvier j'avais fait une faq et vers la
9e minute de la faq je prends
l'engagement stupide de faire une vidéo
nu pour les cent mille abonnés pourquoi
j'ai pris cet engagement parce que au
mois de janvier
crois qu'au moment de cette faq on doit
être 700 sur la chaîne et ça me
paraissait impensable qu'on soit 100
milles avant le 31 décembre
donc pour moi je prenais un engagement à
la légère c'était un truc qu'il
n'arriverait pas donc c'était plutôt
drôle on voit le résultat
ça c'est une bonne prédiction pour un
mentaliste donc je vais la faire je vais
respecter mon engagement et je vais la
sortir je parle toujours de jeux vidéo
le 31 décembre et on fêtera la dernière
vidéo de ce défi de cette année avec la
vidéo je pense la plus spéciale de la
nuit ça me laisse un petit peu de temps
pour aller faire de la muscu histoire
d'être ridicule je sais par jeu
voilà vous savez tout pour ceux qui
suivent vraiment la chaîne depuis le
départ vous savez que je suis originaire
de la rochelle à la base et aujourd'hui
c'est fou parce que la communauté de
menthe à l'eau est plus grosse que le
nombre d'habitants de la rochelle pour
être exact on est plus sur la chaîne
qu'il n'ya d'habitants aux seychelles
mais fait beaucoup moins bon on peut pas
tout avoir
merci à vous tous et elle avoue tout un
parent j'ai vraiment beaucoup de chance
d'avoir une communauté comme vous j'en
ai conscience
maintenant je vais pas me reposer
éternellement sur l'émotion de ouf que
j'ai eu il me reste encore une centaine
de vidéos à faire pour le défi pour
cette année parce que le mental blocks
et vous savez ce que c'est
merci